okay we've got a reason to celebrate oh
it's sona's birth month oh yes where she
celebrates the entire month for her
birthday but this is a big one this is
it's a big one it's 40. yeah yeah
um yeah we're all gonna have big
birthdays coming up I know no you don't
want to talk about it sure I mean my
birthday doesn't come up for another six
months but they're Milestone birthdays
all three of us I don't really think so
I don't think of it that way
um I'm not hung up
on H as they say h is just a number so I
don't think about it much but yeah I see
what your point is these are all going
to be big birthdays let's just come out
with it you're turning 6-0 I'm turning
50 and zone is turning 40 all within
seven or eight months mine is until
April so I don't like being rushed along
mine's not till May mine now that's why
I brought it up yeah oh okay do you guys
celebrate all month I don't like this
rushing thing you know well Conan you're
practically you know 80. I'm like what I
didn't say you just said you don't mind
now you're snowballing it until it
didn't to you being 80. I'm as young as
I've ever been
oh yeah okay oh are you kidding yeah
right especially me and you that's a
youthquake
[Laughter]
I mean we're taking the World by storm
strapping Grandpa these are I guess yeah
these are I guess you would call them
Milestone birthdays that are coming up
as I say it's uh six months away so as
far as I'm concerned I'm 38 years old oh
quite working that's not how it works
that's how it works for me also
um have you seen me I am jacked I mean
do you mean like put up on cinder blocks
and raised like a car is that what you
mean oh yeah I didn't mean working out
yeah no I'm I am jacked I'm I'm
they're working on my undercarriage
there's fluids leaking all over the
floor
the problem was but they can still hear
the buzzing sound
oh God
a beautiful gift this is you celebrate
for a whole month I think I don't even
celebrate for my birthday for a whole
day you know what I love birthdays I
love my birthday I'll celebrate
celebrate all year
weird but I yeah I like celebrating all
month how come you don't like
celebrating your birthday I just don't
you know why I'm gonna be honest with
you I always feel like well I didn't do
anything oh did you know what I mean
like I I one day a year you can't give
yourself the little gift of just hey
let's celebrate me I don't know if it
feels I get a little it's funny because
I'm being
um being honest I just always have felt
like well what did I do I was just
thrust into this Earth against my will I
wanted to stay in
now you're making me doubt my birthday
yeah you wanted to stay in the womb
it was nice in there the minute I came
out I realized there was so many other
brothers and sisters and when I was in
there alone it was you know it was nice
I never was only alone in there for a
little while right yeah I mean exactly I
mean in in my there was just so many
kids that uh many you know a lot of
people can't remember when they were in
the womb I remember and I remember like
this was some me time wow this is real
me time yeah well maybe for your
birthday you could just I don't know
like come back and give it a hefty bag
full of jelly or something and warm it
up and go in there
and listen to something listen to some
songs that were on the charts in 1963.
yeah yeah that's a great idea yeah he's
so fine
no no I'm I'm not anti-birthday but
um I usually my favorite thing to do is
just you know go to dinner as an excuse
to just go to dinner with some people
but the whole thing of hey happy
birthday and here's something for you
always makes me a little self-conscious
it's not the age thing it's just me
feeling
um I don't know it's so funny because
I'm someone who my whole life has been I
love going out in front of people and uh
whatever entertaining them but I feel
like that's something that I'm doing
that's me doing my job as opposed to yay
and what did I do well you lived 60
years I mean that's no small feat yeah I
don't know why you're rushing my
birthday that's unbelievable you keep
acting like it doesn't bother you well
it's another thing to say like well Sona
I mean 50 that's a big one and you're
like what are you talking about well
it's coming up you seem kind of
defensive you know I've got six months
to process this I'm still in in my 50s
and I'm not going to have you turn this
whole segment prematurely into I'm 60
when that's not what I've tried to do I
was just trying to wish someone oh I
know exactly what you're trying to do
happy 50th to you too this is about you
you're practically 57 when you think
about it how do you figure well it's
coming pretty I mean I I feel and look
that way yeah but other than that I
think you use a cane and you don't need
that's an affectation I know gorley has
a walker that he bought at the Rose Bowl
swap meet yeah and he got it because it
was vintage it was one of those really
cool 40s vintage Walkers and he uses it
yeah and I've seen old people who needed
one and you [ __ ] them yeah
no I think I think uh I don't know how
I'm gonna react when my birthday rolls
around but I I think I'll be pretty cool
I do tend to take the attitude that wow
I've been on Earth this long yeah I
think that's how people used to feel
about getting old because nobody very
few people had the chance to get old
Yeah in our recent history yeah for most
of mankind if someone turned 50 or 60 or
70 it was a sign of this is cool this is
wow you've been here and people would go
to you for wisdom we don't do that
anymore with our elderly yeah well
because also we're
aging better you look great you don't
look 60 and you do not well I'm not you
are I'm 59. you look 59 and and six
months no you don't even really you
don't you don't look 60. man I'm
I I'm I might you don't you look fine no
look we don't I think we're all real hot
you don't get first of all Sony you know
that no one just gets my body okay I
immediately regret that's a complimenty
it's an incredible amount of work no one
gets your body they're cursed with it
this body is a burden
um no I uh you know I I do the best I
can but I do have a good body though
that's the thing now it's getting creepy
I mean a really nice body thank you
um
I I'm proud of us because sona's going
to be you're going to be 40. how soon's
your birthday I know I'm supposed to
know this October 13th yeah whatever
I'll have David remind me what I just
told you you can't remember it it's
already gone okay David the other
assistant will remember but
um that's a big deal how do you feel
about turning 40. I'm cool with it yeah
I haven't I should I feel different no
should we feel different I mean I don't
know you've got a wonderful husband two
beautiful boys yeah you've got a really
nice house I'm chilling you're um
working with Conan O'Brien oh God this
is I mean it's the jackpot you know I I
really am like in a happy place I don't
I don't know when you get to the point
where you're like oh like when does a
midlife crisis happen oh it happened to
me late 40s yeah oh okay hard yeah
no I bought a margarita maker oh my God
that was your middle great yeah and had
it installed in his Corvette I didn't
call it my hot rod
you got a margarita Amanda bought it for
me for my birthday but it was my midlife
crisis toy yeah it's actually a Frozen
Concoction Maker from Margaritaville the
Jimmy Buffett brand okay oh wow I hope
you're getting paid no but I would
that's interesting I don't know I'm
gonna think about what I want for my
birthday to see what are you going to
want this year I like just a dinner with
friends but it's 50th so maybe we'll
have a party or something I don't know
right that's just something in the
backyard or something what about you
Sona what's the plan for this well it's
birth month so it's a lot of dinners
with a lot of people and then uh my trip
a trip with my family really entitled to
have a birth month how dare you oh I'm
sorry just to say oh and this whole
month is mine where do you get off
saying there's a lot of people I want to
see and so it's like hey let's you know
use your birthday is an excuse to see
people no Isn't it nice but it's also
pressuring them to get you a gift nobody
gets gifts anymore it's not like I'm
turning you know five I I don't want
people to get me gifts no one get
get I don't want to do a gift thing I
expect a gift on my birthday you want me
to get you a gift yes it's especially
this year so much stuff why do you say I
have so much stuff because you're a very
wealthy person it's all relative I mean
compared to Bill Gates it is hard to buy
you a gift it's not a hard person to buy
a gift for not true okay it's true what
really yeah anything I'm happy with
anything as long as it's costs over like
twenty five hundred dollars I'm happy
with it can I just write you a check
that's fine okay yeah no my limit check
for 2500 and you would catch it my
Baseline is twenty five hundred dollars
that is my Baseline I just collect
checks from your employees
my mother a few years ago made wrote me
a little note on my birthday and I sent
it back to her and I said this I want 2
500 minimum
and she didn't she didn't have it she
had to take out a loan you should just
build into our pay for the company an
extra 20. come on you guys do fine and I
think
um I'm a i Loom large in your lives and
I think uh twenty five hundred dollars a
piece is fair uh check is fine I prefer
cash or crypto okay I wouldn't know what
to do with crypto I just I just
transferred crypto into your account
then you know what I know so little
about crypto I'm assuming you did oh
yeah
oh oh
I guess I guess if I heard boop boop
then I must have crypto
coin and I gave you 25 000 biggie bits
well I'll use some back okay I'm gonna
give you some
thank you
well this ended stupidly yeah it did
happy birthday Sona